I actually went to audition for Jerry
Maguire Tom Cruise was doing you know
Jeremy old time crew so I go to read but
as I'm reading I'm loud show me the
money show me the money
you know what I mean right that's all
I'm saying brother show me the money Tom
Cruise reads his line but it was like
this
so I thought he lost his place because I
couldn't hear him so I said we write he
says I know I set the line and waiting
on you I'm like oh
anyway I didn't get the part and you
know of course Cuba Gooding got the part
and anyone else but I had to learn how
to bring it down and then later on I did
collateral with Tom Cruise and then got
nominated for
um